foreign
I said that is a lot of wood
I'm gonna build a fire over this Frozen
part to thaw it out I'm gonna put some
fire in that trench as well
all right got a nice bit of cold some
really hot sand we'll spread it out nice
and even
get my bed ready
well it's been about five hours since I
buried the uh coals let's check the
temperatures got 89 degrees right there
76
and 59. definitely still got Heat
man you can still feel it
here's my pillow for tonight
I must have been tired because it's 5
a.m and I slept pretty good so I stood
to fire up really good and that feels
really nice my feet are really cold so I
rolled some logs down that way and built
a fire
and uh hopefully that'll warm my feet up
here in a little bit
oh good morning well the ground's really
hard but I'm warm the uh Fire by my feet
is keeping my feet warm I feel some
warmth in the ground still well I'm
curious to see how warm the the gravel
is
I mean that's still pretty good so we
got about 60 degrees here
and we got about 22 degrees over here
so yeah big difference
I'll tell you what sleeping on 70 degree
gravel versus ice and water makes a huge
difference ah she's been a good shelter
but it's time to go home
[Music]
there we go
let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
looks like it's about 17 degrees out
here let's take this inside and see what
the difference is we're gonna put this
right up here
by the bed check it out it's about 43
degrees here in the shelter so that
means it's about 26 degrees warmer in
the shelter versus outside so that's
really a big difference
that should be pretty comfy and he can't
roll out
well it's about 9 30 in the morning and
we're just watching the sun slowly come
up we're just kind of packing up and
eating breakfast taking it easy now we
got the place cleaned up a little bit
let's get Jacob out of here
all right
hold on
foreign
Bud uh-huh good
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
there we go it's pretty cozy
well guys it's getting late I'm gonna
turn the camera off and go to sleep I'll
see you guys in the morning
well good morning guys oh looks like we
got a bit of snow last night that's why
you hang up your coat in your pants
that's why you cover up your boots
yeah we got quite a bit of snow
oh yeah
well it's time to get packed up so I'm
gonna go put the fire out
you got it
foreign
[Music]
I did
foreign
foreign
foreign
one bird in a tree
so the answer is wrong so it's not this
one because we are not
[Applause]
okay
[Laughter]
foreign
that'll do
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
High Heat spray paint meant for
barbecues and stuff
[Music]
foreign
fire not too bad huh
[Music]
alrighty
foreign
foreign
it's really smooth and surprisingly
Square considering
so cold all the plastic is frozen
hopefully nothing breaks
you have to kind of insert the pole the
elastic's not very stretchy at this
temperature
all right got step one done I better get
this thing off and go
oh
my lips are getting numb it's hard to
stalk
the tarp so Frozen and crinkled it's too
small to fit in all the grommets I'm
having to yank on it for all my worth to
get it to stretch and go where it's
supposed to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there we go
we got heat well it's four o'clock and
we're already busting out the flashlight
yeah I want you to sit down right over
here is that warm
[Music]
there we go so this thing right here is
a water tank you put a bunch of snow in
here or water whatever and uh it heats
up against the side of the stove and
then you can just turn this
get hot water whenever you want it you
gotta admit that's awesome it really is
all right got a caribou hide down here
on the grounds could take my boots off
oh that really helps up here the very
top of the tent it's 98 Degrees the heat
from the stove Rises and collects at the
top of the tent so there's real extreme
temperature differences in here my
head's kind of sweaty but my feet are
kind of numb let's put the thermometer
down here and I'll show you the
difference so check it out here on the
floor it's right around freezing at 32
degrees I have another thermometer here
on the bed and you can see that this
one's at 60 degrees so that makes a huge
difference in temperature just being off
the floor a little bit every inch off
the ground you get in a hot tent the
warmer you're gonna be that's why you
use cots in these things it makes a huge
difference to being a cot versus on the
ground
and thermometer says
negative 58.
oh
it's cold this tent is made by Arctic
oven and the model is called the igloo
I've heard people claim it's the warmest
hot tent in the world and I think
they're right
[Music]
I'm going to bed guys I'll see you in
the morning
Jake you up and Jake both woke up too
hot uh the middle of the night at some
point but it's about 9 A.M and I'm gonna
get the fire cranked up then we're gonna
get up and make some breakfast
foreign
man that is so close to negative 60. it
is bottomed out this thermometer oh it
is cold guys
all right guys we're at that point where
I gotta put the fire out once I do to
race against time to get everything put
away before my fingers and feet freeze
my lips are going numb
foreign
I think this looks like an awesome spot
let's find some dead trees
[Applause]
thank you
I'm gonna build the shelter out of a 12
foot by 12 foot tarp in a couple of
these poles
this is my winter well titanium
backpacking stove it only weighs a few
pounds this thing is so light
and it's really easy to put together
the stove pipe will melt the tarp if it
touches it so I've got to use these Fork
sticks to keep the tarp away from the
stove pipe
foreign
well we're getting ready to go to bed
and I have learned my lesson from
previous winter camping trips I brought
a wide neck bottle yeah
we're not getting out of our bag tonight
good night buddy
oh it was cold last night my bag was
barely keeping it together
hey Nathan were you warm
Nathan's bag is so much better than mine
I gotta get one of those as much as I
hate to say it I think I need to get
dressed and get up and doing stuff it is
cold
in case you're wondering how I secured
the tarp to this rock face
I just had these little wooden wedges
that I jammed into the cracks right
there and over on this side I tied it
off to an icicle now we're gonna get our
tarp off without letting it touch the
stove and get melted like I did last
time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
about six and a half feet tall with my
boots on so the snow's just a hair under
six and a half feet deep
and at the top of the wall it's about
nine feet
oh
foreign
big enough
I guess I don't need my shovel well I
better get going because I need to get
my tent up before my wife and kids
arrive
are you okay
all right
all right guys I gotta I gotta show you
one feature of our ice compound here
we've got a bathroom
got our toilet paper
a little Camp toilet all right my sweet
wife is putting the boys to bed I love
you you're a hero
foreign
it's late but we got everybody in 110.
going to bed I'll see
you man we got a lot of snow last night
check it out
Matt's tense barely visible
well good morning how did you guys sleep
good
Hey Mimi did you sleep well
yeah were you warm
good
look at this place
man
it's turned out to be quite the shelter
a lot of snow got moved by hand it's
time to get all my gear home I gotta go
dry it all out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
not too bad that's going to be pretty
cozy tonight
foreign
[Applause]
well this bed sure is a big Improvement
holy mackerel
can you hear that
that's a whole pack of wolves but I
think we're gonna be nice and safe
wolves are no wolves
that's about as sturdy of a shelters
I've slept in in a little while so I
think we'll be all right
see you guys in the morning
[Music]
can you go that way
yeah yeah I'll come with you
a lot more
hey get down in there and lay down and
see if it's flat and comfortable it's
pretty soft but dry first things first
um I think we need to get a bunch of
firewood
[Music]
there is a little bit of a breeze coming
in around that corner and uh if we can
get rid of that breeze it's going to
warm up really good in this little
crevice so I've got a tarp that I'm
going to try to string over that opening
foreign
really good and now that Fire's heat is
really getting trapped in this space
between the Rocks it's it's warming up
pretty nice
you feeling better buddy
oh it's a lot warmer in here isn't it
okay this is about as cozy of a survival
shelter as I've ever had but there is a
little bit of a problem here we're
getting dripping this is going up here
and melting all of that ice and it's
coming down here and it's running here
and then it is dripping onto my sleeping
bag it's dripping right about there it's
dripping right about there it's dripping
right about there I'm hoping in a couple
hours it might dry up a little bit and
we might get rid of this problem but in
the meantime I better move my sleeping
bag or it's gonna get wet well guys we
got kind of lucky there fires melted
when it's going to melt and the dripping
stops so I don't think we have to worry
about getting wet in the night from cave
drips
well good morning it is 7 A.M and the
Sun is just beginning to rise you sleep
well Nathan
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I could be getting old but it seems to
me that the worst part of sleeping in a
survival shelter is the lumps on the
ground so lay down in your shelter a few
times find some good positions smooth it
out because it's a lot easier to fix it
now than in the middle of the night
foreign
[Music]
instead of sleeping bags we're going to
be using this bison Pelt this thing's
like six and a half feet by seven and a
half feet it's massive
oh
there you go buddy
all right buddy you warm
are you comfy
all right you need to go to sleep buddy
well good morning it's about seven a.m
and uh we're a pretty toasty warm
foreign
that is a very delicious campfire donut
right there
[Music]
this looks like a gorgeous spot
the other side of the lake
all right you're focused on one you'll
do
yeah
all right we got a roaring fire in here
and it feels amazing come on in
Nathan you awake
yeah he's like I got the phone though
take it out in here is nice we can see
here inside the town on the floor it's
about 22 degrees Fahrenheit maybe 25.
and if you look at on the walls you can
see there's frost on the inside of the
walls below about here so from about
here below is 32 degrees and the higher
up you go in the tent the warmer it gets
until it feels like 70 degrees up here
well I got the door of the stove facing
towards my bag and I've got a pile of
wood with an Arm's Reach
all right guys it's pretty late I'm
going to bed I'll see you in the morning
well guys we survived the night
and look who's up
hey Tom you're nice and warm
oh
look how covered in Frost my overalls
are
thank you oh these pants are cool all
right we're
almost 32 degrees so right hovering
around freezing inside the tent
it is cold out outside the tent it's
negative 16 degrees Fahrenheit that's
negative 26 Celsius oh it's cold today
this tent's been a good little tent for
us I'm actually really pleased with it
it's super light it only weighs about
four pounds for the tent and the stove
but uh it's the seek outside four man
teepee hot tet and I'll put a link in
the description to it but I need to
start packing it up and getting ready to
go because uh we're gonna run out of
daylight here in a little bit
foreign
I'll tell you what this might not be a
bad place to sleep for the night it's
got a flat Sandy bit right there got
some water some dead wood
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
it's like a greenhouse underneath this
tarp
it is so warm in here man it feels so
good and warm here on this Gravel Bar I
can't even begin to describe it here I
need to bust out my thermometer and show
you guys so I've got two thermometers
and you can see right here the Ambient
Air Temperature is about 34 degrees
Fahrenheit so just slightly above
freezing but I put another thermometer
here in the sunlight over here on the
Rocks check this out look at this
on the Gravel Bar it is 80 degrees 80
degrees Fahrenheit so there's a 46
degree difference between the
temperature of the air and the
temperature of this river bank that is
massive I'll tell you what it feels
pretty amazing on this Riverbank right
now but all that's going to change
tonight when the sun sets it's supposed
to get down to about 14 degrees
Fahrenheit so we need to store as much
of this heat as we can and store it in
our shelter I'm going to show you how to
do that really easy
foreign
build up a nice big bonfire right there
where I'm going to sleep
it's going to heat up the ground store a
lot of energy down in the Rocks those
are going to dry out the ground and it's
going to make it really warm inside the
shelter
foreign
[Applause]
there we go just move the fire over a
little bit bury the coals with a little
bit of dry sand
and we're gonna have a really hot
Foundation to put our shelter on top of
foreign
guys it is warm in here my legs are
cooking
this sand is just hot with the coals
underneath it and I've got the heat of
the fire
and then it's just not that cold out
here because I'm sitting on this baked
sandbar
just absolutely great
I'll tell you what guys I think I might
be getting a little bit of a cold
tell you what I slept really warm last
night I never pulled down the side of my
tarp and the fire went out and I was
just really good last night
it was really nice
it's cool though
we're good
foreign
yeah I'm gonna throw it over here
well the fire and the shelter are doing
a great job nice and warm in front a
little chilly on the back but not bad
it'll probably get down to the negative
numbers tonight and I think we'll be
just fine as long as we can keep this
fire stoked
well it's about 10 p.m and Nathan is
snoring away
look at him he's just snug as a bug in a
rug I'm doing pretty good I'm staying
warm my back's a little cold but it's
not a big deal
but mostly I'm just on the lumpiest
piece of ground there's this weird bump
and it's kind of hard to find a good
comfortable position but
wake up
you slept in a lot
foreign
all right
we're accomplishing three things with
this fire one is we're making the
shelter a little bit bigger thawing out
the ground making it warmer and we're
leveling out the ground by burning out
all the stumps and Moss and little
things so that we can have a nice flat
warm surface to sleep on
[Music]
away
oh yeah
is that nice and warm
foreign
there we go got the roof covered in Bow
so if we get a good dump of snow tonight
the tarpon cave in Hey Jake there's your
stuffed animal buddy
Jake you want some hot chocolate
I'll tell you what though this is as
cozy of a winter shelters I've ever made
it is so much warmer in here all right
I'll see you guys in the morning
oh good morning
um bed wasn't too hard that's not too
bad
definitely got snow last night
[Music]
I have no idea how deep this snow is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
every time you dig one of these things
you never really know what's going to be
under the snow you could have big stumps
or rocks or you know who knows what
luckily we just got a few willow bushes
so we're gonna get those out of the way
all right now I just need to put a roof
on it so that if we get a big dump of
snow tonight we don't wake up under a
foot of snow
foreign
I hope I built this roof sturdy enough
because if we get a foot or two of snow
it's gonna get really heavy but we got a
lot of cross members to try to
distribute the weight and we'll see what
happens
foreign
mattresses don't work as well in the
cold
there we go
there you go Lee blanky time
foreign
well guys I have slept better tonight
than I have in a long time we slept 10
and a half hours it's almost nine
o'clock right now and the sun's still
not up well we got a bit of a storm last
night
oh yeah we got some still up there
definitely got some snow last night all
the firewood's covered in snow yay
all right
foreign
so much just couldn't hear how loud it
was it's really roaring out here
all right Nathan should we pack it up
and Snowshoe out of here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's not a great roof but I'll keep the
wind off us and if we get a little skiff
of snow shouldn't be a problem
let's get it into the shelter
when you build these shelters you want
to make them in a zigzag s pattern so
the wind never can have a straight shot
into your sleeping area it helps a lot
and you know these little logs you can
buy for the fireplace if you don't want
to build a proper fire well I got like
half of one of those
whoa that feels nice on the hands my
fingers have been so cold on this trip
this little chunk right here will last
about two hours so between that and this
I've got about four to six hours worth
of campfire right there temperature is
dropping out here it is cold
oh
I'll tell you what the wind is
absolutely howling down in the valley
it's wind chill is below negative 15.
but we're really sheltered where we're
at we're right up against a hill and
next to some trees and then once you get
down below the the snow line it's uh
nice and still in here so you're not you
don't have that wind chill to deal with
all right thermometer says zero degrees
Fahrenheit all right we're going to take
the thermometer down here see what the
temperature is at our bags
we can see down here by the sleeping
bags we got about 16 degrees Fahrenheit
so definitely cold but a lot warmer than
it is above the trench and that's the
beauty of snow caves if you build them
right they're always about 16 15 degrees
Fahrenheit No matter what the weather is
like outside
all right guys I'm getting to bed
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
good morning oh my goodness we slept in
so long
well Hey Jake you awake
hey good morning
[Music]
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more Adventures from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe because we put out new videos
every Saturday morning thanks for
watching guys I'll see you next Saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching